hey friends and welcome back to rapid  fire language learning today we're  answering the question how to learn  words in a foreign language  learning words is not difficult but you  need to know how to do it here's my  suggestion you need to have  three things in place first you need to  listen to read and watch as much  interesting  and comprehensible stuff as you can  second you need to have a system to  capture  all the interesting and relevant words  and sentences  you stumble upon when you do so and  third make sure that you have a system  to review these words  at least for three minutes a day for a  long period of time if you do this  you will not need any checklists lists  of words  and key flash cards you will just learn  as efficiently as it can get  if you want to know more about  vocabulary acquisition and any other  aspect of language learning  please check out my channel over and out